just doesn't care about being accurate,
doesn't care about any of this. People
have asked him about this. He'll never
respond to it. He has no response. If I
knew about a creator, you know, making
death threats, trying to dox people, I'd
probably try to distance myself from
that community. Also, the the ultimate
irony of ironies, okay, the ultimate
irony of ironies is I happen to care. Do
you remember exactly what Willy's take
was when he knew that Queen and I were
getting threatened with like we're
getting dox threats, death threats? Do
you remember what his take was? Do you
guys Does anyone remember? These two are
so unlikable. Even when they're being
target threatened with their docks, I
can't help but notice how big of losers
they are. Lol. Lol.
I can't recall if there's more to this.
From here, I'm going to probably start
going over to the Willy Mac stuff. All
right. Cuz I think it's very interesting
that food traps would raise Willy Mack
is like, "Oh, they all say he's pro
Destiny." As if that's like the most
insane thing you could think. Now, is it
the most I don't know if it's the most
insane thing you could think. I haven't
really claimed it. I've said he's
probably like a useful idiot for
Destiny, right? He's too dumb to
understand how he is just plating
Destiny's audience. That's definitely
true, but I don't think I've ever said
he like is intentionally trying to help
Destiny. That doesn't make any sense to
me with how Nicholas so harshly
denounced Destiny, so harshly separated
himself from Destiny, and then Willie
Mack and Nicholas are like close
friends. That doesn't that wouldn't make
sense to me, right? That's basically him
like in a way starting to separate from
Nick, and I don't think he'll ever do
that. So that's just that's not a part
of like my mental model of who Willie
Mack is at all. So I don't think he'd
ever do that intentionally.
All right. Okay.
So we'll go back. We'll go take a look
at this. Willy Mack has said that I
apparently have attempted to dox him. So
let me go down to this right here. So
this is the first post here. We'll get
to we'll get to Desi response to this
after. We'll we'll get to that in just a
little bit. Okay. We'll get to that in
just a second. But uh so I believe this
is on a on a fail doc's picture of me
that Destiny himself has retweeted and
like a whole bunch of people basically
Destiny says no this is definitely him
and like keeps trying to post this over
and over again which is kind of funny to
me that he has any smoke for bad
empanada right very very strange to me.
Uh yes, this is also being posted in the
Taliban. Now Willie is saying, "Hey,
don't do that." Right? And this isn't
the only time Willy's done this. Willie
has posted another time. It's a It's a
fail doc. Okay. Allegedly, that's me,
but it's not. Uh okay. Anyway, so as
someone who's doxed, who was doxed many
times recently and has had it spread
very rapidly, I think people should
respect Jtox's ask for privacy when it
comes to his face. We've I've I've said
this isn't me. We both talked to each
other, but we have left it on the
internet. I don't like seeing it spread.
not necessary at I can't even remember
what he said here. The tweets are
somewhere. I think I pulled the tweets
out and gave them to somebody, but um
they're still up as well. And then he
says, "I actually completely take this
back as I'm currently seeing JTO retweet
my docs, my bride's docs, and the
location we are going to be at. LMFAO
very based." Okay, does that sound like
something I would do? How long between
those two tweets? This is I mean it's
less than an hour, right? If it was more
than an hour, they'd be more than an
hour apart. So, it's less than an hour.
That doesn't sound like something I'd
do. So, here's what he's actually
referring to. Dickers made a tweet.
Okay. Dickers made a tweet criticizing
Destiny for quote tweeting Gatafumodor
who posted a bad empanada clip where bad
empanada on screen pulls up some pieces
of information on Willie Mack. Okay,
it's censored up pretty significantly,
right? It's censored uh but not enough.
Sorry. It's It's censored up pretty
significantly, but it's not enough. Like
I I wouldn't like it personally if if
people were quote tweeting that about
me. Okay. And Dickers responded to
Destiny, replied and said, "Destiny is
against Doxy now." question mark. And
then he got blocked. And that's like
what I'm retweeting, right? I'm
retweeting like, "Oh, Dickers called out
Destiny for being like a total hypocrite
on doxing."
The two Willy tweets are 24 minutes
apart. Okay. So So
anyway, it's that's what I'm retweeting
now.
Dickers was himself quote tweeting a
clipper from Queman's community I think
who clipped Queman. Queman didn't look
at this video had it muted and it was
playing in the background and some parts
of this Gata Bumador video played on his
stream. I don't even think he was really
paying attention to it. He just let it
play in the background. Right. But it
was Destiny's quote tweet he was
watching it through. So he's like, "Oh,
Destiny's posting this." Like I'm just
like he the video was playing while he
was complaining about Destiny being a
total who can't possibly who can't
possibly criticize bad empanada. Okay,
that's like the whole point of the
tweet. I retweeted Dicker's tweet that
included that quote tweet. Okay, so
there are some pieces of information
about Willie in this video that I was
unaware of. I only listened to Queen do
it, right? I was like on Twitter and I
hit play on this and I went to another
tab and was doing something and
listening to the argument he was making,
right? So I was broadly unaware. Not
that that makes like a massive
difference, but it seems like Willie is
saying now that if you if you were to
quote tweet or retweet somebody who is
disavowing doxing in the neighborhood of
dox information about you that that
makes you responsible for doxing them or
for that dox, right? Which is strange.
So regardless of the tone, so my tone is
doxing is bad. I am I am broadly in a
culture of I I think doxing is very bad.
I do not dox people. I do not want
people doxed, right? I'm totally against
all of this stuff. And that is the
sentiment of the tweet I'm retweeting,
right? And so Willie also against
doxing, also asking people not to dox,
right? But by doing so by replying and
and himself, I'm sure he would admit
because he probably thinks I'm
amplifying amplifying tweets that
include purported docses of me. So I
don't know where he's standing on a high
horse here exactly, right? And I don't
know how he's going to say this, but
very funny enough, Destiny puts his foot
in his mouth here. Okay, Destiny
complete utter doesn't realize that all
this happened from his tweet that
originally had 219,000 views. Okay, it
probably had way more than that where he
is quote tweeting this exact video. Quan
was looking at the Destiny tweet, right?
So clearly Destiny is far more guilty of
doxing Willie Matt than anybody else,
right? Than anyone else. But he's
posting in the Taliban. He regularly
reads the Daliban. He engages with that
community totally. By Destiny's
rationale, by the way, Willie, I hope
you know, by Destiny's rale, you're open
to like so many things by participating
in this culture. Okay. Luckily, luckily
for me, I actually have a lot of
sympathy for Willie having information
about him and one of his loved ones
posted on the internet. And so, I
understand how he could possibly be uh
like hesitant to or he could possibly
get heated and post something that he
shouldn't have, right? I don't think
there's any reasonability to the claim
that I doxed him or his fiance. I don't
think that's reasonable at all. Right.
I'm literally retweeting something
critical of doxing. All right. Hold on a
second. Let me let me take a look at
what else we got here.
Oh, I also was linked to this Gat
Fumodor
clip and I didn't even pull it up on
stream. I didn't want to draw any
attention to the fact that any of this
stuff happened. Personally, when I saw
it happen, I would not bring up the
tweet. I timed out and some people here
can actually like confirm this because I
know I timed people out for bringing it
up. I literally timed people out in my
live streams for bringing it up or for
posting the tweet or for even like
mentioning it. Right. If you dox him
then Destiny did yet he didn't go with
Destiny at all. Yeah. I would think that
his whole problem would be with Destiny.
Right. He's posting the Dow then.
Shouldn't he be very very very upset
with Destiny? And I'll say as far as I
know, as far as I know, he hadn't like
reached out to anybody. Eventually
Destiny does delete this tweet. Dickers
deletes his tweet as well, right? But
it's like I don't think I don't think
Dickers was ever trying to dox somebody.
I don't think even the Clipper was
trying to dox somebody. Realistically,
nobody even knew that that stuff was in
the video until Willie pointed it out
cuz nobody the video is like happening
in the background. Stuff's like
minimized and stuff. It's like not
incredibly obvious unless you're looking
at it as the person who is incredibly
invested. Right. Anyway, so I'm on
Willy's side here. I think doxing is
really bad. I think you shouldn't dox
people. I I was not in support of
anybody doxing that guy. I was not in
support of anybody spreading that or
amplifying that. Okay? Obviously, I
retweeted dickers just pointing out the
hypocrisy.
And by the way, if he by the just so
we're clear, if this if if criticizing
doxing or amplifying any tweet
criticizing doxing, if it adjacently
includes some doc information, even if
it's like by far not the the main part,
although for Willie, he's criticizing
something that it is the main part. So I
don't even know, right? No, it's not the
picture of me as fail docs, but again,
purported docs, whatever. Right. So, so
he is to his mind, like we we just have
to step into his mind. His mind is that
is real and don't do that, right? He's
criticizing don't do that. But he's now
criticizing me for amplifying a tweet
that happened to include some
information downstream about him and his
fiance apparently. Okay, which is
literally the action he is doing by
replying to these tweets. Like to be
clear. All right. Now, I find it just
interesting that we go to all of this.
Oh, let's look at the the Destiny
response here. Desessie responds, "Just
take solace in the fact that there's a
non-zero chance of Cherry murder
suiciding both of them within the next 6
months." Uh Desi, of course, being a
complete He's friends with Cherry. Uh I
I'm in a relationship with Cherry.
Obviously love Cherry. Okay. Now,
non-zero chance. The best part about
this is I think Cherry would say, "You
know what? I don't know about this part,
but the murder part almost certainly."
Okay. There's a very real chance of
that.
That's a very There's a very real chance
of that. Okay. Do you think she's
Listen, you've heard her speak about
Canada. You think you think she's going
to let herself get buried in Canada? No
shot. No shot. Okay. Anyway, uh but it's
Destiny backing him up. And Destiny, of
course, feeling no shame at the idea
that he is in fact, okay, he is in fact
the person amplifying the Willie docks.
The thing Willie is complaining about is
something you did a thousand times
worse. 100 times worse. Okay. 100 times
worse. Why are you even commenting? Why
is Willie posting in the community in
the community in the Twitter community
of the person who spread his docs more
than probably anybody who spread this
docs more than Destiny? Is there
somebody who spread this docs more than
Destiny?
>> Canada doesn't care about that. Well,
neither of them care about that, right?
Willie is just trying to get a dunk on
me for some reason. He like he's just
got a whiff of my ass and he he can't
get enough of it. Okay. I only comment
on him being on the internet. He's like
barely regarding Willy's comment anyway.
Yeah, he's he's just trying to, you
know, trying to upset people. Hold on.
Cherry did have a good response to this.
Okay, wait. Let me let me pull it up. Go
out of here. Where is it? Here. Where do
we have Where do we have What is it? Um
Oh, I should find the community post
that goes along with this. Okay.
Char responded to this. Give me a
second. Some of you may not know this,
many won't as I briefly reposted about
it only 10 or 12 times, but I will be
heading to Canada for two weeks to try
therapy or what? You know, we don't even
know. This could be rope therapy, ripe
therapy. I'm not totally sure. I've been
wanting to make a series called Get Soon
and record my experience trying
different modalities of for anxiety,
generalized mood issues, and pursuing
happiness. I designed a self-report
measure with validated measures for
depression, anxiety, and psychological
wellness. I am super hopeful you guys
enjoy this series. What I want you to
know, what I want to know from you is
this. What questions would you want
answered on a video that is per both
personal and empirical on theory? theory
is how it sounds. You get to work on
mental health. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
This is This will This will be a
self-guided process. So, what are your
questions on the experience? Post them
below and your questions may end up in
the final video. This is of course a
reference to a Yeah, I know friends.
This is of course a reference to a not
so erodite community post. Oh, let me
try to find this community post here.
Where does at where at? Uh oh. Uh,
somebody asked me to Hold on. Can I just
give me a second? There might be a
thread of people discussing this. Okay.
Yeah, we'll we'll see this. Okay, we'll
see this. Oh, hold on. Let's Let's check
it out. Clip live. Can anyone prove that
JTO retweeted Willy's docks like Willie
claims here? The only evidence I can
find from that date is a repost of a
Destiny quote tweeting Willy's docs.
Yeah, Willie is okay with replying in
Destiny's community. Oh, look. De's nuts
asking the exact question we should all
be asking. Wait, why is he like posting
there at all?
Also, wouldn't your post here be
amplifying somebody else's docs?
Shouldn't you like actually understand
what's happening before you do that?
Cherry memes way too hard for me. Okay,
that's that's crazy. JTO will be the
I mean I mean Dr. K. Jesus Christ, dude.
These are spicy. But but I can't not
read them. I can't not read them. I'm
sorry. I can't read funny I can't read
funny messages and not read them. I
wonder how many psychological ex
psychology experts have hot tub hot tub
khole on their resume. Okay, let's check
this. Let's check out some of the So,
this is the clip live subreddit, guys.
There's a couple things here. Yeah, so I
reposted the dicker tweet and Destiny
reposted this tweet. All right. Uh let
me know if I've missed a repost. I even
checked the Twitter of Ry Kitten host
Jox editor. I couldn't find the repost
where he mentions here. Never happened.
just never happened at all. Okay, never
happened. But I was going to tweet about
this and I was thinking about it. I was
gonna go, look, it's Willie. Once again,
another another episode of Willie not
being able to read or engage with any of
the media he sees online. Okay, yet
another instance of him not
understanding what's going on, making
claims that he can't back up or or about
at all. He's back again to do it again.
It's crazy.
Supposedly, Desi deleted the post after
Lumpy Willie tweeted at him. Can't
confirm, Lau. Props to Dickers for
screenshotting. I also went to look only
on Jtock's Twitter like 20 minutes after
Willie posted his reply saying Jtock
reposted it and I didn't see anything.
Well, that would be I didn't even delete
the repost. By the way, the the actual
retweet was of Dicker's post. So, it's
this guy knows about Dicker's post and
he posts about the the retweet here,
right? He's got the retweet in the
thread. So, I retweeted the Dickers
tweet, but when Dickers deleted his
tweet, it disappeared from my timeline.
Yeah. Uh, I also went to look blah blah
blah blah blah Chase. Yeah, it's true. I
literally didn't. Uh, wait, was that
genuinely Willy's bride? I was 99% sure
it was some random woman and the guy bad
up that found. Okay, so I'm going to
keep looking past this. I really don't
want to. Okay, I thought that was a
gross and terrible harassment campaign
against Willie and Tommy, though. Why
would Willie lie about this? Why would
he, by the way, why would he go to
Destiny's community specifically, right?
Can we think about this? Why would you
go to Destiny's community specifically
to make this claim? Can we think about
the the the effects of making that claim
in Destiny's community? It's almost like
It's almost like, okay, he's willing to
ally with Destiny against me. And what
what would it for me to claim that he
could be pro Destiny in any way? Huh?
Personally, if I knew about a creator,
you know, making death threats, trying
to dox people, I'd probably try to
distance myself from that community. You
know what I'm saying? Personally, I
would just probably try to distance a
little bit. I'd probably try to be like,
"Yeah, I don't really want to engage
here a whole lot. This seems a little
up, right?" Especially when you want to
then virtue signal about similar things
happening to you. then it gives you a
leg to stand on that you aren't like
participating in that community that and
amplifying stuff from that community
where that's happens right this is by
this is desgu except desi has no
evidence that I do it is oh he's allowed
to dox people because apparently I
support kib farms or something right
that's his argument
I don't believe that but by that
rationale if you believe that rationale
supports this stuff right he
participates in that culture would be
open but not by mine okay I don't think
you can do this to Willie. I think doing
this to Willie is bad, right? Probably
got after trying to stick up for you and
out with a Jtock is bad. He might have
gotten, but he he legitimately thought I
did do that. So, it's just it's his poor
engagement with the with the post,
right? It's him not understanding what's
going on in the post and getting
emotional. I understand the emotionality
part is up, okay? But I will I will
criticize him because it's his job. He's
supposed to post accurate information.
He's supposed to be accurate, right? And
he fails to do so repeatedly. He fails
to live up to like a reasonable standard
over and over and over again. And that's
the criticism. Okay, I'm not even going
to criticize the emotionality of it.
That's understandable. Okay, let's keep
reading. I sympathize with Willie for
being doxed, but he is an has an
unhinged hate against Jto even though
Jto is a gaylord. Well, that's not true.
Kind of provably so now, actually. Hey
buddy, is is Hey buddy, is that really
criticism? That's a gross haram
harassment campaign moment. To be
honest, I get why Willie hates him. That
guy went on asperggo complaining about
his Destiny video, especially claiming
No, I didn't. I literally didn't. I
literally just said he wasn't getting
the whole story. I I went on a stream
two minutes into the stream. I was just
like, "Hey, I I woke up and I was like,
"Hey, I jump on and just point out
something, right?" I corrected his uh
his position on Kelly. He totally
totally out to me on that. Totally
agreed with what I said about the the
Kelly stuff. And then I wanted to make
the point I think about getting the the
cherry storyline and the pattern of
behavior correct right in the video. And
I didn't I didn't specify that well. But
I don't think that that wasn't me like
complaining about it for months or
something. Didn't do that. Uh basically
what's happening to me is something it's
something similar to what happens to one
of the creators around Hassan where like
you know even though he has no
participation Shawn Black's blamed for
CPS, Shondaanda Black's blamed for uh
what else? CPS and skulls and all of
this, right? We have bad things that
happen to somebody and I'm going to say
there's a creator who's sort of adjacent
to that. I'm going to blame them for all
of it. Anyway, I agree. JTO did look
like a complete in that situation.
Again, Willie agreed to the the
correction on the the Kelly stuff. Like
basically, shouldn't you have asked
Destiny? The question was, shouldn't you
have asked Destiny for some evidence of
the thing he was claiming? He's claiming
something fairly negative about other
people that they're posting revenge porn
of him, right? Shouldn't you ask him for
evidence of that? Yeah, obviously you
should. runs from uh but Willie just
lies about and about that and runs from
people like Jtock and Queen and reflects
poorly on him especially because Willie
seems to somewhat still be somewhat
still favorable towards Deafne which is
pathetic.
Willie took down the tweet so I think he
probably got it wrong. JTO is still a
spur regardless. Yeah, Willie did not
take down the tweet. Willie still has
the tweet up by the way just so we're
clear. I think it's very embarrassing
for him to do that. I think he's like
being a total weirdo. I think there's
probably eight creators that he should
be going at before me, but he thinks he
thinks he could just farm, I guess, that
community for likes and follows about
me. This is probably what he's done for
almost all of his uh he's it's probably
what he's done for almost all of his
content, right? Is he just tries to find
somebody to farm, but usually he's
drafting behind Nicholas or usually he's
drafting behind other creators who are
intelligent enough to evaluate media on
their own. Um, this one he seems to be
going off on his own and it's having
predictable results. unlucky.
Okay,
now here's the thing. People will say,
"Oh, well, the the Destiny thing doesn't
make sense. He's not somewhat favorable
towards Destiny." Um, this isn't the
first time Willy's let his madness at me
get in the way of any critical thinking
or reading skills, right? Or made a
totally totally insane critique of me
that it doesn't map onto reality at all.
Right? So, so what happened here?
Destiny posted this. And to think this
was the same guy who spent the last year
saying having sex with mentally ill
people equals crazy, huh? Everything
Destiny is saying here is true. Lol.
Everything Destiny uh I've never said
that. That would be an insane thing to
say. I literally have people with mental
illness in my life who I care about
deeply
and I always have. By the way, this is
like this is a totally How would I have
relationships with those people and
think they're incapable of having a
romantic relationship? It's bizarre.
It's unhinged. is insane. I don't know
why I would ever why you would say I
said that. Okay. Well, I know why
Destiny just lies about people, right?
That's why deathy would just lie. And
Willie doesn't care to be accurate or
correct. Care enough to have with uh at
least one of them. Yeah. Only mute.
Anyway, so just doesn't care about being
accurate. Doesn't care about any of
this. People have asked him about this.
He'll never respond to it. He has no
response. You other mentally ill people?
Dude, listen to me talk. Yes. It depends
on what you mean. Like I just don't
think mental illness is not a thing that
you can just put on somebody and say
like, "Oh, it's wrong to have with
them." That would be insane, right? That
would be totally insane to make that
claim. At least I was just joking
because obviously I was referring to
family members as well. So I was just it
was just a meme. Don't worry about it.
Yeah. So I just But I wouldn't I
wouldn't denigrate those people in their
agency, the people I do care about by
saying you can't have with them or have
any romantic relationship with them.
Yeah. Anyway, but Willie Mack totally
amplifies this. Doesn't care. doesn't
care about being accurate when it comes
to me. He'll just totally lie about me
and nobody will call him out on it.
Sorry, not nobody. Nobody around the
Destiny community or anybody there.
Nobody there cares about truth at all.
Queman orbiters, Chud and and J getting
targeted. Um, no. Everybody gets
targeted, right? Willy Mack is not mad
at Queman. Willy Mack is not doing the
thing where he's mad at Queman and
coming after me. He's mad at me. He's
been mad at me. He's obviously been
angry at me. Okay.
Also, the the ultimate irony of ironies,
okay, the ultimate irony of ironies is I
happen to care, but do we remember do we
remember exactly what Willy's take was
when he knew that Queen and I were
getting threatened with like do we're
getting doc threats, death threats? Do
you remember what his take was? Do you
guys Does anyone remember? Does anyone
remember?
These two are so unlikable. Even when
they're being target threatened with
their docks, I can't help but notice how
big of losers they are. Lolol
lolol
lol
which he is lucky I understand Willie
doesn't deal with people like me but I
actually just have a principle here and
I still even though he said this am not
going to say like oh is open nothing
like that right I still think it's
really bad to dox people I still don't
want to participate in that culture
whatsoever it's crazy right and it does
suck for for Willie Mack and uh
especially his his fianceé, right? His
fiance's had stuff published. Like it's
it's it's super like that. I have every
amount of empathy for that, but I didn't
participate in it like at all. This guy
is dumb. He is very dumb. Okay. He is
very dumb. He is very dumb. It's but
it's like it's just funny and like
almost borderline embarrassing how wrong
he can get things and nobody goes, "Oh,
that guy's a complete."
He's obviously a complete and people
don't see it. I don't understand how
they never see it. Wasn't it that other
website? Well, I didn't dox him. Yeah,
obviously not. No, I think it's up.
Anyway, trying to think if I've got more
here on the Willyax stuff. I got more on
the Willyax stuff. Oh boy. Um, I've got
a lot of issues with his first video,
but I I think I'm going to wait on that
to pull some of those things out.
Anyway, Will's like a to complete,
right? I just don't understand JTOK.
Nothing against Cherry, but you were
really willing to risk your reputation
to be with her, someone you know is
unstable. There are so many other women
out there. It just doesn't make sense to
me. Well, Jack Stack, I want you to
imagine. Oh, somebody just banned that
guy, I think. Wait, what happened to
that guy's message? That guy's message
just disappeared for me. Oh, I see.
Yeah, that guy got banned. Okay. Um, I
don't You don't have to ban that. That's
like a reasonable question. I
Yes. Just Yes. Yes. I knew exactly what
the outcomes would be. And yes. And by
the way, that's because it's somebody I
hung out with for hours every single day
for months and months and months and
months. I don't I have no Is that a
reasonable question? I mean, it's not a
reasonable question to ask again, right?
Yes. I I understand that people would um
I understand how people interpret
that. Like I I get it, but I think
they're just wrong. I think I care about
this person like super deeply. And yeah,
if that if you if you feel like you
can't trust me because of my personal
life, my decisions in my personal life
made between like two consenting adults.
I care about this person. If you feel
like you can't trust me given that,
that's fine. Off, right? Just walk. Uh I
I've said this to this is like one of
the only times I'll get um even remotely
personal again. Okay? I don't like
getting personal on stream, but
something that's all the thing that
blocks me in relationships is never the
fact that um it's never like any of the
big things like it is for other people.
It's never like attraction. It's never
anything to do with like or romance or
anything. It's that in small moments
dayto-day, I kind of can't stand some
other people. Like I I just have a hard
time like getting along with people most
of the time, right? And I don't have
that problem with Cherry at all. Like
it's just always fun to hang out with
them. That's what it is. Okay, sorry.
That is just what it is. Now, I
understand that people have concerns
about how that might overlap with my
content and I I understand that that
could be concerning. I'm working through
that. Yeah, I'm working through that.
Okay. So, like 99 90% of long-term
relationships, I guess. So, but like
yeah, that's just that is what it is.
That's always going to be what it is.
I'm sorry that uh I'm sorry if people
thought I was like enough of an incel to
to never do that. Uh Spruce Willis, I
don't think so. Don't believe so. You
way overjustify yourself. I'm not
overjustifying. I'm just telling you how
I feel. That's just how I feel. Okay.
It's changed your whole content. Wait,
what? No, it hasn't. I I think that's
crazy. I don't know where my content's
changed. The content's like the exact
same. Yeah, I I don't know where the
content changed. Anyway, Kev likes Oh,
Kev is a huge NSE s, isn't he? Oh,
right. Yeah, I think Kev is like a huge
This is gonna be hard for him to accept
your intelligence for the way Kev name a
criticism you have of any of my takes.
Just go ahead. I'd be happy. You want to
lay out you want to lay out a take I've
had. Okay, I'm willing to defend, but
you're just you're like you don't like
the vibe because we criticize not soite.
That's like a totally different thing,
isn't it? I think you're the one who
changed, Kev. Okay,
you formed a parasocial relationship.
You're very uncomfortable. You're in
criticism. That's okay. You're going to
make it. My criticism is that you mute
yourself unintentionally. That's true,
Germaanium, and I cannot beat those
allegations. All right. You talk about
the Ria Chris stuff. I haven't gone 15
minutes without someone bringing it up.
No, I'm good. Defending NY is fine. If
you want to actually defend her, but I
don't think that's what ever happens,
right? What happens is somebody goes,
"You're insane. You're obsessed with
this person. You're totally obsessed
with this person." Okay, that sounds
like you're claiming I have bias against
them. should be that I have a bunch of
takes against them that are totally
incorrect. Why don't you grab one of
those takes and say, "Hey, hey, can we
talk about this?"
How easy is that? That should be so
easy, right? I I that's all I want to
hear, right? Instead of instead of, "Oh,
you're so obsessed with this person." I
want to hear when you said this, this
was really unhinged and I disagree with
it. I watch this is by the way, mock
Rabbit perfectly encapsulates nearly
everybody who who is involved in this
conversation right now. I defended Noto
Erdite until I watched any of her
content. Then all the hate made sense.
That's basically it in a nutshell. By
the way, some of the debate content like
Noto Erdite, I've always said this and I
will always say this, okay? She's like a
fantastic like loud lal for blood sports
debates. She is. That's just that's just
facts, okay? It's very funny. It's very
good content. If she's screaming at
somebody in a debate, there's a 50-50
chance she's completely wrong and
doesn't know it. And that's awesome. We
love to see that. 50/50 might be high.
I'm not totally sure, but there's
there's a decent chance she's actually
completely wrong and screaming at
somebody over a thing that she's unaware
she's wrong on. You you get that very
very very uh rarely from people. Okay.
Oh, yeah. Somebody somebody basically
asked Willie Mac Show and some other
people. Oh, he replied and said, "So,
you're going to go at I'm not going to
pull it up cuz uh Oh, hold on. Let me
see real quick. Let me see this. I'm I'm
going to look at this lumpy Willie
tweet. Give me a second. Give me a
second.
Make sure there's no doc stuff there.
There is not. Okay. Yeah, it's just me
reposting the dickers tweet. And like I
don't know why you would be mad at me
for that and not messaging other people.
Like why wouldn't you message the person
who posted that? Or maybe he did
eventually before going at me, I guess.
Okay. Am I am I all done with the Willy
Mac stuff? I think I've shown quite a
few of the things. Oh, and Willie Mack,
just to say again, I understand he's
like he's basically gone to the Destiny
community and made multiple posts there
under like them attempting to dox me or
them showing ported docs pictures of me
and said, "Hey, you guys shouldn't do
that, right?" But again, if you're
critical of doxing, but amplifying those
those docses, there's like a philosophy
there where you just don't acknowledge,
you don't ever talk about it at all. And
there's a philosophy where like you you
decry it. But I don't understand how you
can like mix those two. Either decrying
it is okay or it's not. All right, I
think that's it. That's it for the
Willyax stuff. What do we go on to next?
Was there more Hutch stuff? I'm not sure
if there's more Hutch stuff. I've got
one of two options here. Oh, wait, wait,
wait. There's a there's a Destiny
comment as well. Hold on. Apparently, I
got told I should watch this Destiny
stuff. So, before we go into some longer
form content, I will possibly go to Nuck
Boys. No, I'm not doing I'm probably not
doing the Iron Mouse stuff. I don't have
any of that stuff available. Second, if
you wanted to go collect links for that,
I would absolutely do that story. I'm
just probably not doing it today. But
there's Nel Boys interviewing Benjamin
Netanyahu and then they talked to Nick
Fentes and then they talked to like they
talked to Nick Fentes and then Hassan
and then Sneo and then Hassan again. All
right. And I've heard that basically the
entire time this was going on, Destiny
was watching and messaging them to try
to get on the stream and they were going
to bring him on the stream and then Oh,
and Myin. Yeah, and Myin. And then and
then they went and uh they just didn't
invite him on. They brought Hassan on
again with Adam Freriedeland at the end
instead of inviting him. He's like
waiting there to get on. He messaged
them waiting waiting waiting and then
they talked to Hassan and Adam Freeland.
They go, "Oh guys, we're out. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye." So I think there's probably a
lot of content to mind there. Okay.
There is a lot of content to mine there.
I think it's it's also like sort of a
who's who of former Destiny friends as
well. They were asking Hassan about
having banned people on. That's
definitely why. Oh, good times. Good
times. Oh, Kev Kev99. We all saw that
content already at Destiny stream.
Everybody here was there. Okay. I'm just
so happy that people are psyched to
watch it again. We to watch this guy get
Imagine. I wish I was you, Kev. Two
opportunities to watch this guy be
humiliated. I wish I was you right now.
Okay. I wish I already had that memory
there and then we were loading it up
again to watch it happen again. God, it
sucks that I'm actually just watching it
for the first time. I don't watch
Destiny. I know a lot of people here
don't watch Destiny. I just thought I I
wanted to read his in the soy voice and
laugh at him. That's all. That's it.
That's all. Okay. Somebody provided this
time stamp in the Discord. Let's Let's
check this out real quick. Some of you
may know that um many won't as I briefly
posted about it only 10 or 12 times, but
I'll be heading to Canada for two weeks
to try therapy.
>> The mind of the battled attempts to
understand humor attempts to comprehend
humor. Let's see how this goes.
>> Um
you think that this is her? Um so I
don't know what this is or I'm sorry. I
don't know why, but Cherry is obsessed
with um Cherry is obsessed.
Again, just go to any of the actual
factual criticisms and point out the
ones that are wrong, right? You'd think
it's so you would think it's just so
embarrassing for somebody who had this
youth to dismiss his criticisms for
years by Hassan and he'd always point
out how it was, right? For him to just
go and throw this at other people, put
no work in himself, no effort in
himself, right? Because he'd have to, by
the way, what he'd have to do in that
case is defend his very close friend
apparently who he thinks is very
intelligent. Does that sound difficult?
How how hard would it be to to defend
your friend who is very intelligent,
right? Very intelligent, very good at
debate, very smart from somebody who's
obsessed and unhinged and crazy.
Shouldn't that be really easy? I feel
like it should be really easy, but I
just never see anybody do it with Kyla.
I don't know why. Um, this thing here,
apparently Kyla is trying like ketamine
therapy or whatever. Obsessed, but
Destiny is reviewing a 17 like tweet.
I'm just glad that Desi is driving
follows and stuff to the cat post irony
account. Okay,
get it? Because it's like a cat post,
but also post irony. Cat post irony. You
guys get it? These tweets are her um
making fun of Kyla's ketamine therapy
stuff or whatever. That's what she's
doing here.
>> Yes,
>> that's what this is.
>> Yes, that is what it is. Your JTO,
you're going to end up in a tweet one in
a cherry tweet one day. You're gooning
to your own cancellation. Uh, listen, I
understand and like every single part of
Jerry, okay? It's just not a problem for
me. I'm perfectly well aware that like
there have been tweaks made about me
publicly. I don't care. I don't care.
>> Was that public knowledge? Yeah, there
was some YouTube comment I think that
she posted a while ago.
>> Oh, nice. Somebody pulled it up for us.
>> Oh, is he going to read it?
>> Um,
>> yeah. Yeah. Some of you may know may not
know this or some of you may know this.
Many won't. As I briefly mentioned on
stream only once or twice, but I'll be
heading to Boston for two weeks to try
ketamine therapy.
Cherry obsessively stalks like every
single part of Kyla's life that she can
online and talks about her like
incessantly. It's probably one of the
reasons why just
>> Cherry Cherry just watches content and
then tweets clips and other clips there.
>> Is also focused on it cuz Justin has to
do whatever he can to keep his um new
BPD queen from keeping herself.
>> Oh, Cherry's manipulating me. I thought
I was manipulating Cherry by being Dr.
K. It's really hard to keep track.
things get get criss-crossed and then
I'm like very apparently
we're we're we're stuck in a cycle.
Okay. A symbiosis. All right. What is
the uh hold on? Yeah. A orus. Okay. I
was trying to think of the snake like a
oraoris. Right. Both people are at the
same time. I I don't Some people Some
people might call that a relationship.
Okay. These people are both invested in
each other in a way. Yeah, some people
might call that a relationship. Other
people call that mutual, I guess. I'm
not totally sure. I don't think we're
done yet. Okay.
>> Miami made to kneel to eat.
>> I think there's some more stuff here.
>> Is ketamine therapy crazy or something?
Doesn't it have legitimate use?
>> Did I really just do that? Whoops.
Whoops. Some of you may know this, but
um many won't as I briefly posted about
it only 10 or 12. There we go.
>> Constantly. Oh, somebody asked about the
ketamine therapy, right?
>> Is ketamine therapy crazy to do or
something? Doesn't it have legit uses?
Um, yeah. I mean, there's trials.
>> You do that a lot? I do that a lot.
Yeah. I've got a I've got a trackpad.
It's slightly sensitive sometimes.
>> Know where the trials are at right now?
It's obsessed. That's lame.
>> Why do you use obsessed? That's lame.
>> Oh.
Oh, somebody's pointing out, "Hey,
didn't you teach me that it's like
really lame when you just dismiss
criticism as obsession? Isn't that like
lame to do?" I could have sworn
Excuse me. Excuse me, Dad. Excuse me,
Dad. Uh, I thought you said like
dismissing people's criticism by saying
they're obsessed was like really gross
and gay and probably made a joke about
how only people who suck come do it. I
don't know why you do that all the time,
but you I think you usually make jokes
about people who just like drink [__]
It's kind of weird. But anyway, I
thought you said that it was weird to
and and like [__] drinkers only do that
that they say somebody's obsessed. Okay.
I'm pretty sure like the whole account
is Cherry constantly posting about every
single thing that Kyla
>> says or does.
>> Is it
>> I feel like there are definitely a lot
of other things.
>> Okay.
>> But also, just to be clear, even if
that's all it was, that should make it
super easy. If she posts all the time
about all the things Kyle is doing
wrong, that should make it super easy to
grab a couple tweets and go, "This is a
crazy This is like a crazy take. I would
This is something insane." No.
>> Or whatever. But like that's that's
>> Yeah. Nobody ever says this exostasis.
Why can't Kyla just stop saying stupid
things?
>> Could we It'd be a lot easier for
everybody to move on if she could just
stop saying really
and entertaining things. Okay. That we
get to laugh at her. I'm sorry. There's
a reason that there's an entire industry
just laughing at this person, right? You
go on YouTube, you just laugh at this
person. It's like plus 200 viewers.
>> Um old Twitter account. Nice block.
Techone update. Kyla.
>> So, Teone and Kyla.
>> Yeah. Content from today.
>> Hutch calls into food shop stream and
adds the submitted P OCD to team
liberal. Queenman can't even get a call.
Oh, Cherry's also
backing just
>> so here's not a not a K post at all
>> thing here because I think um
>> wait, hold on. Wait, what?
>> Traps stream adds the submitted P team
liberal queen can't even get a call. Oh,
Cherry's also backing Justicle's thing
here because I think Dang, that's a lot
of Kila tweets. She is so jealous.
Okay, Kev, you need some time out. Okay,
or if you want, you can go to the
Discord and make an actual argument
against one of the posts. Okay, good
luck. You can have some time off. Oh
god. Oh no. Oh no. Hold on a second.
Hold on a second. I'm going to go ahead
and say it. Okay. I believe that Kev99
GH guy may possibly be one of the first
candidates for the Incel ranch. All
right. I think I think there's a lot of
evidence that that could be he's hoping
to get in line. He's hoping to make it.
Okay.
He he is a 30-year-old teenager who
needs his to be fixed. Okay. His insult
to be fixed. All right. I think um
Queman wanted to talk to Hutch or
whatever and I guess Hutch decided not
to do it and
>> Hutch was like literally told, "Oh, this
guy's like a total like loser who will
never give you a good faith
conversation." Hutch was told by
somebody else, Hutch didn't make that
decision on his own, right? He got
information from somebody somewhat close
to him.
>> And because Cherry um is being used and
mind by Justic, she's also on team
orus. Okay. Yes. First, Cherry was
convincing me to do all these things and
then now I'm convincing Cherry to do all
of these things. It's the Oraoris. Okay.
Over and over and over again.
>> Oh no, we've got a surp
what the wrong criticism is. He can't
get a clip and say here's what you up.
Doesn't do it. Doesn't happen.
But okay, the extra ad of or whatever
sounds like Lil Stevie is still playing
dumb. wanted to talk to Hutch or
whatever and I guess Hutch decided not
to do it and and because Cherry um is
being used and mind by just also on team
like oh no we got because these guys are
all like
>> circle and trying to help each other
constantly
circle and trying to help each other
constantly. Oh, wait, wait, wait. I
understand. Hold on. I understand what's
going on here. Destiny doesn't
understand. There's like a very, very
crazy concept that went on between
Cherry, me, and Quimman that Destiny has
never been a part of and can't fathom,
and that is the concept of friendship.
He doesn't understand friendship. He
doesn't understand people being friends,
like hanging out, you know, after a
stream in a public Discord or something.
He cannot fathom it. He cannot ponder
it. It makes no sense to him, right? He
said there's nothing there. There's
nothing there. Oh, by the way, this is
another non Kyler tweet. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, hold on.
>> Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
>> So, this happened. So, okay. Wait, wait,
wait. I need to go and see all the
tweets. We're going to scroll through
>> several trying to help each other.
>> Oh, so not a not an Aerodite tweet. This
is an Aerodite tweet. Unfortunately, we
covered some Aerodite content back to
back. So,
>> not so Aerodite. Oh, not so aerodite.
>> Not aerodite. Not erodite.
>> Destiny gaslights. And so
>> wasite. Now I will say there was a lot
of Ky there's a lot of statements to
point out. Okay. It was good content.
This debate was really good content. The
whole thing was
>> not so erodite. Not so aerodyite.
>> Not not so arroite. Not not so arroite.
This one's not so arroite.
>> Uh retweet of arise. Oh, not so
arerodite.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Destiny, why don't you play some
of these clips? Hold on, hold on, hold
on. Cuz here's the thing. I've said this
already. Even if this was all Aerodite
clips, only Aerodite clips. Why don't
you play one of the clips and explain
the problem with it? Right? Where does
she lie? Where does she say something
incorrect? You're just going to go and
you're going to do the obsessed meme,
obsessed BPD queen, obsessed BPD mind.
Right? It's just a
It's a Marov chain of unhinged woman
terms instead of actually looking at
one. Destiny, go watch that clip where
she goes, "Do you know who Destiny is?"
Well, Destiny says that Kyla is really
good at debate and like does a really
good job. Would that change your mind on
Kyla? Why don't you go watch that clip
and then I get to watch you your soul
die. Okay. And then tell me you want to
restart the Bridges podcast. All right.
Please do it. Oh, not so erodite. Oh,
not so arerodite. Oh, not so Yeah, she
was obsessed. Like, he didn't watch any
of the clips. He didn't watch any of the
clips. He didn't make a comment on any
of the comments she made, right? Zero
commentary. Zero clips watched. Just,
oh, it's a Kyla clip. It's Kyla clip.
It's a Kyler clip. So, I guess probably
in the same vein, right? In the same
vein, if we go to any clip creator who
focuses on a sub community or on a other
creator explicitly, can we just not
trust those clips? Well, shouldn't it be
really easy to just go through those
clips and say, "Oh, that's not relevant.
That's not relevant." But he can't hide
his hatred for her either. Notice he
doesn't call her by her actual name. Too
close. Couldn't wait to close that last
clip. What was the last one?
>> Oh, not Sarite.
>> Hold on. What was it?
Let Let not Serite say, "Stop checking
people for the past.
>> Just watch any of the clips, bro. Go
watch the clips and explain to me why
that's not funny." Yes. to be. So,
here's the thing, and I I benefit from
this sometimes, too, okay? Not as much
as Ardite does. Everybody who defends
Arerodite tends to be people who don't
watch Arodite content. And Cherry's just
making it so they can see like the
moments why everybody else rejects it.
Why the people who have tried watching
it reject it? She's literally helping.
She's helping everybody.
Credit Cherry. Hold on. Yeah. You know
what? We actually should watch some of
them right now.
>> You're kind of based. We're trying to
recruit you.
>> Based in what? I haven't said anything.
You said,
>> did you imagine? I just want I want to
challenge Destiny to watch this on
stream. Watch this clip on stream.
>> Steven was intelligent. That is Loki
based.
>> You said that Steven was intelligent.
That is Loki based.
>> He is. You don't you don't debate and
not have like a high level of
intelligence or like an understanding of
how those types of conversations work.
>> What if I told you
>> his job literally requires his
intelligence? I wouldn't deny that. What
if I told you that Steven regularly has
said that Kyla or not so arerodite is
really good at debate and does a really
good job.
>> Okay.
>> How would you feel about that?
>> Is he God? I I don't Is he God? I don't
care,
>> dude.
>> Okay.
>> Why
>> do you think I like Do you think I value
his opinion on who is good and who's bad
at debate?
>> Well, it seems like you value his
opinion on a number of things. So, it
would be weird that you would
>> I thought you said he was smart. Uh, is
he not the strongest man in the room to
you? Do you not listen to him over your
husband? Am I am I on an island here
where I think Destiny's word is like law
and and like I I just think he's really
smart and really good. Destiny's like
really deeply good, you guys. Okay. And
I know I said that his path to
redemption meant like, you know, writing
wrongs and admitting fault and being a
better person. And he's done none of
those things, but I think he's redeemed
and I think we should all go on tour
with him. Okay, let's go. Okay. All
right. Where was I? Oh, I wasn't done
yet. Unless he's done. Is he done?
>> Arerite.
>> I think he just says obsessed over and
over again, right?
>> Oh, not. Yeah, she's obsessed. Like she
has been for years,
but
>> she has been for years. I think I think
Cherry feels like Who is it? Okay. Oh,
man. Cherry's got to feel like like a
journalist covering Prince Andrew or a
journalist covering the the Catholic
Church where like a massive scandal is
happening. Millions of people are being
brainwashed into thinking this person
has something valuable to say. And
Cher's the person who like sees it and
she's like, "Dude, do you guys not see
how stupid this person is? Does nobody
see it? Does nobody see it? Hello.
Hello. Hello." She's like, she's found a
conspiracy. And by the way, lots of
people do see it. It was just I'm Walter
inside the car screaming. Lots of people
do see it now. And I'll just say, uh,
Queen makes a bunch of, like Queen gets
a bunch of views doing that content. I
get a bunch of views doing that content.
There's a bunch of people who see it who
see like the the contradictions and like
the over the performiveness that like
makes us all cringe. We all see it now,
but Sherry was the first one who pointed
out. I knew the whistleblower clip was
bad. I told I remember telling Aaron I
literally told Straight, "Hey, why don't
you point that out how that is?" Right?
I I said to Aaron, "Why don't you point
out how that is?" And then Aaron pointed
it out, but I didn't like, "Oh, man."
Then I let Kyla come on my on my stream
and say, "No, actually, I looked that up
and I was right." I was like, "We should
just move on because I don't want to
engage with that comment, guys. We
should just
We should just move on." Okay, we should
just all move on. We should just Let's
not talk about your whistleblower
comment anymore. Okay, that's not a good
one. We don't like that. Uh, okay. Oh,
why is this Kev99 GH guy in here? This
guy was unhinged.
You don't know the context of what
happened with Destiny. You're surrounded
by mentally ill peoples. Clemen need to
get sued by Destiny. Cleman is a Jtock
orbiter trying to bang Cherry next in
neither here and there or their
Minecraft. She's more likable than your
dumbass. Go read a book. Oh, this is
like Kyla. Destiny's going to win this
guy. How did this guy survive so long
saying like this? He was here for a long
time. The whistleblower stuff. Destiny
said NC is a good debater. Not soite. If
she is correct, she she if she is
correct, she optically is like a decent
blood sports debater, right? She will
she'll like hammer somebody on a point
and it's very good. But the problem is
there's like not a connection between
how correct she is and that level of
confidence. So sometimes there have been
times where she will absolutely like
mock the [__] out of people, right, who
are correct while she's wrong. And it
creates this really weird disconnect
that is hilarious.
That's that's like my favorite part
about her. Those are like the funniest
moments. It's the whistleblower moment.
That's like
chef's kiss. Okay. Anyway, okay. Hold
on. We're looking around. We're looking
around. Uh yeah, I should I should be
able to set a timer for my gen chat. I
didn't realize Gen Chat was still
locked, guys. Apparently, Gen Chat's
still locked. Who knew? Not me. Not me
at all. Okay, what are we doing now? We
are
Hold on. What are we pivoting to next? I
think it might be the Yeah, it might
just be Here's the thing. I want to go
on to the BB Net and Yahoo stuff. Okay,
I kind of want to go on to that. But at
the same time, now that we just did all
of that, listen, now that we just did
all of that, my my programming came my
mind is starting to kick in. I'm like,
technically Aerodite did did interview
Teeto today. Should we go cover infinite
air content? Okay, I think so. I think
just because I could put that on the
back burner for like a day. I think I
want to go do the Netanyahu stuff. But
I'm I'm so tempted in a spiteful way to
go do all the Aeronite stuff again.
H Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I
did want to just cover Destiny like
fuming about Hassan really quickly
before I get into the the This is like
during the Nekboy stuff. One second. One
second. One second. What is this?
The Why did this time stamp not work?
Uh t equals 3 uh 9632.
I don't know why this time stamp didn't
work.
>> A war criminal by the international he's
such a Oh my god. Look at that graying
disgusting.
>> Also, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Before
we check it out, before we check it out,
guys, we're going to end on Twitch. Go
over to kick for the rest of the stream.
I love you if you're on Twitch, but
we're going to kick for the rest of the
stream. Thank you very much for watching
on Twitch. Don't forget to throw your
Twitch Primes on your way out. Okay,
Twitch Prime reset day was today. Lots
of people have their Twitch primes
reset. Do heard I just got here? No, I'm
good. Uh, I'm good. I'm good. I'm good.
All right. Where are we going? Where are
we going? Oh, yes. Ending the Twitch
stream, guys. We'll see you over on
kick. Okay. We'll see you over on kick.
We're ending the Twitch stream. Bye-bye.
Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom. Boom.
Boom. Boom. All right. Here we are.
We're headed on to this. We're
continuing with the Destiny content.
>> Just like a podcast there. You know what
I mean? Like he's literally the prime
minister that is a war criminal by the
international
>> God. He's such a Oh my god. Look at that
graying disgusting
beard. What? Did he stop? Look at that
gray disgusting beard. What a
Okay. Um, you are literally a You
literally drink [__] You lit You are
literally like more disgusting to
everybody on the planet than Hassan.
There's literally not a single person on
the planet who finds you less disgusting
than Hassan. I'm sorry. It's there's
just literally nothing there, right?
It's it's so bizarre. Also, pretty sure
people like the salt and pepper beard
for Hassan. Let's see. Let's see.
>> International.
>> God, he's such a [__] Oh my god. Look
at that graying disgusting beard. What?
Did he stop dying the rest of it? This
old
>> 50year-old unmarried disgraceful to his
bill.
>> God. Oh no.
>> Their [__] family is his brother.
>> Oh no,
bro. Is there a single Is there a single
one of those criticisms that doesn't
apply harsh more harshly to Destiny? Is
there a single one? Is there a single
one? No, that applies far more to
Destiny. Disgusting beard. Far more to
Destiny. Embarrassing to his loved ones.
Far more to Destiny, bro.
Oh, wait. Hold on. Hold on.
>> 50-year-old unmarried disgraceful.
>> I don't believe Destiny's currently
married.
>> Billionaire. Is his brother at least
married? Is somebody making kids for
these degenerate losers?
>> Is somebody making kids for these
degenerate losers?
>> Oh god.
>> So many children.
>> Did any of the wealthy college women
that he did any of them have any kids?
God, I hate this.
>> The wealthy college women that he Okay,
bro.
This guy's falling off so hard. It's
amazing. Do you remember when Destiny
was the guy who was like, you know,
guys, I hate Hassan. Everyone knows I
don't like Hassan, but I'm going to be
fair to Hassan and say like this.
Remember when he was that? And now he's
just here like taking all of the things
that people laugh at him for, okay, and
trying to flip those onto Hassan. This
is like insane projection. This crazy
projection.
>> This guy so much. Imagine going on a
show like this and being like a war
criminal. Meanwhile, this dude has a [__]
reservoir built up of nostrila in his in
his in his closet that he sits there and
chugs while he's got No, he did it
again. He did it again. There's no way
that he just did another come drinking
joke. I literally mocked him for this 30
seconds ago.
Dude, this guy cannot stop thinking
about drinking [__] at all times of the
day. He can't help it. He literally
can't help it. It's so weird. It's so
weird.
Like everybody else just says you're
sucking somebody off or you're meat
riding, meat watching, meat riding.
Okay, you're glazing. Every accusation
is a confession. Dude, dude, it's every
one of them. He can't go guzzling
buckets of dude.
Videos of dead Syrians in the background
playing because he loves Hezbollah. He
loves every terrorist as long as they're
against Israel, I guess.
>> Ask him.
>> Unless they're against Israel. He loves
terrorists unless they're against
Israel. I think he loves them if they're
with against Israel, right?
>> Dead Syrians in the background playing
because he loves Hezbollah. He loves
every terrorist as long as they're
>> against Israel. I guess questions unless
people want to know.
>> Got it.
against Israel, I guess.
>> Ask loves every [__] terrorist as
long as they're
>> I guess
that I think people wanted to know.
>> Okay. Okay. What did he What did he say?
I mean, of course. So, for starving,
>> I don't know if there's anything else
here said that they bring the food in
and steals it.
>> We're going to watch a bunch of these
interviews, by the way,
>> and then sells it.
>> No, that's a lie.
>> Past does not possess the gene. That's
why he's angry. Uh, sure.
We know that. Okay. We know. We know. We
know. We know. We know.